valérie pécresse est la candidate de la
feuille de paie pour que le travail paie
plus nous augmenterons les salaires nets
de 10% en cinq ans avec une hausse de 3%
dès juillet 2022 soit 500 euros minimum
par an pour un salarié au smic nous
défiscalisent rompt totalement les
heures supplémentaires sans restriction
ni plafond nous permettront aux salariés
de convertir leurs rtt en salaire nous
ferons enfin la réforme des retraites
qui emmanuel macron n'a jamais eu le
courage de faire pour revaloriser les
petites retraites afin de garantir un
minimum égal au smic net valérie
pécresse ce sont des mesures concrètes
pour lutter contre la hausse des coûts
de la vie nous baisserons la tva sur les
taxes pour faire baisser les prix de
l'électricité
la taxe sur la taxe ça suffit nous
indique seront enfin les indemnités de
frais kilométriques sur les prix des
carburants nous généraliserons le prêt à
taux zéro et pas seulement dans les
zones tendues pour que la propriété ne
soit plus un luxe mais une réalité
accessible à tous nous mettrons fin à
l'injustice des surprimes d'assurance
que doivent payer les français en
risques de santé dès qu'ils veulent
emprunter pour mener leurs projets
immobiliers ou professionnels valérie
pécresse c'est aussi la candidate des
familles et des plus fragiles nous
relancerons une vraie politique
familiale en réinstaurant les
allocations familiales dès le premier
enfant soit 900 euros par an et nous les
augmenteront de 15 % pour les deuxième
et troisième enfant pour aider les
familles et les personnes dépendantes
nous nous relèverons les plafonds des
crédits d'impôt pour les emplois à
domicile nous augmenterons de 54 % à 75
% les pensions de réversion pour les
conjoints survivants
enfin on des conjugale is wrong
l'allocation pour adulte handicapé pour
ne pas pénaliser les bénéficiaires qui
vivent en couple et qui risquent de
perdre leurs allocations
[Musique]